Yamcha Finas Keshava shuffled us we can
do this a rallying call made by Angela
Merkel a year ago Germany took in over 1
million refugees in 2015 but the mass
sexual assaults in Cologne on New Year's
Eve and radical Islamist terrorist
attacks have swung public opinion the
right-wing AFD party founded in 2013 is
stirring up the rhetoric against
refugees and could even overtake Mackel
Sparty in her own federal state with a
year to go till the national elections
the Chancellor is under massive pressure
can she counter the skepticism
with state elections held in
mecklenburg-vorpommern on September 4th
campaigning is well underway in
lipnick's dumb garden Magus Christian
Democrats have recruited a local sailors
choir to boost their presence the town
is located within Michals parliamentary
constituency but she's here today to
lend her support to the CDU's candidates
for regional elections as the clock
strikes eleven however the party
faithful are still waiting the Eternity
the fiddling party or alternative for
Germany are already here represented by
candidate Ludovic us his campaign is
focused on opposition to mcih the AFD is
targeting discontented voters especially
those disappointed with mces policy on
refugees class finds her motto we can do
this abhorrent it's completely
uncontrollable Germany haven't just
saved the world scares me it's bound to
go wrong that's a bit more modest
instead of this megalomania directly
adjacent and on the other side of the
political spectrum or the left party
normally they're always against Angela
Merkel and the CDU on principle refugees
however are another matter I have a very
critical view of miracles general
politics but in saying we can do this
she expresses exactly what I feel it's a
goal i likewise hope and work for it's a
challenge we want to solve how she goes
about it is another matter
these are bond fusses something mecha
could explain here today first however
she goes for a mingle around the Market
Square where she visits local traders
selling their wares good news the honey
is regionally sourced the Chancellor is
not here to talk politics the main point
of events like this are photo
opportunities images of Angela makka
cozying up to the people and vice versa
although here would be a rare chance to
gauge real opinion on the street on
refugees for example
it's too much there are too many of them
I always say we were refugees ourselves
after the war we came from what was then
Stettin I have nothing against refugees
what we need now are a few clear-cut
answers to reassure the population I
believe in the slogan we can do this but
what I'm missing is a clear statement on
how to do it so there are people willing
to listen to Mackel accept their
Chancellor chooses the safe option she
talks about a range of issues faster
internet connections boosting tourism
less bureaucracy but on critical issues
angle immaculate remains vague of course
we want security social security job
security but also security from
criminals and Islamist terror this is
the major challenge currently facing us
equals off GABA for the AVM obesity the
major challenge of refugees goes
unmentioned instead a sing-along of a
regional Mecklenburg folk song
the angry crowd shouts that makkal must
go discontented voters here in the state
capitol Shailene are an ideal audience
for the alternative for Germany party
refugees are something these people know
only from television although less than
15 thousand live in the entire state of
mecklenburg-vorpommern this is the issue
that gets most people worked up there
needs to be more done for our own people
as well there are a lot of refugees
coming in who don't belong here let's be
honest it's awful we women are now
afraid to go out at night mrs. Merkel is
a narcissist who is unable to admit
mistakes the star here in show theme
today is Veronica from Julian he
represents the fervently right wing of
the AFD his arguments are well received
here and it's always the despised
Chancellor and her refugee policy that's
to blame millions of people came here on
mass last year or invited by Angela
Merkel and her colleagues in the old
parties into a national crisis the
national crisis is apparently the fault
of these people in the summer of 2015
Europe saw refugees entering Europe on
an unprecedented scale and the numbers
of people coming from Syria Iraq and
other war zones mostly via the Balkans
continue to increase when tens of
thousands were stranded in Hungary in
appalling conditions the Chancellor took
a fateful decision an open-door policy
on refugees effectively rendering EU
Asylum rules redundant the flesh ties
all that Duty also means providing
protection to those who deserve it the
Geneva Convention on refugees applies to
every member of the EU not just Germany
a decision of conscience argued the
otherwise pragmatic
it resulted in the arrival of an
estimated 1.3 million people
local authorities soon struggled to cope
here in Berlin it took some refugees
months to even register as refugees it
was not the kind of organizational
display Germans expect from their
government as for the Chancellor she's
made this the issue in her political
legacy she's invested more time and
effort promoting it than any other
subject with a promise that became the
motto for her refugee policy we can do
this if we encounter obstacles will
overcome them people across Germany
followed that call with donations or
actively helping out countless local
groups organized everything from cookery
classes to German language courses but
others extended a different kind of
welcomed refugee homes were set on fire
as protestors in a number of towns
openly voiced their hatred that hatred
has also been directed against the
Chancellor McClure's response to being
called a traitor was unusually emotional
unfunny if we now start having to
apologize for putting on a friendly face
in desperate situations then this is not
my country then if the smile and noise
today let's is another stop on the
campaign trail in mecklenburg-vorpommern
MCEs CDU party has invited local
tradesmen and managers to discuss
business policy with the Chancellor
officially refugees are not on the
agenda today but Mackel knows her
audience is keen to hear her views on
the subject of course we can also talk
about refugees at the cabinet meeting
today we discussed refugees and the
labor market where we see problems and
what we can do both gunmen often then
something surprising happens instead of
refugees people at the meeting prefer to
discuss topics ranging from aspects
dentistry degrees - specifically local
issues such as a road bypass did the
Chancellor get a lucky break only at the
very end of the meeting does a man take
to the microphone and bring up the
question of refugees openness concern
madam Chancellor do you not believe we
may have brought the danger of terrorism
to Germany with the asylum seekers
tsunami and Islamic terrorism or is is
not a phenomenon that came to us via the
refugees we already had it and it's not
the job of our security services but
there have been cases of imported
terrorism in July a man from Syria blew
himself up in an spa injuring 10 people
this was just days after a young Afghan
refugee seriously injured for in an
accent knife attack on a train outside
votes book both perpetrators claimed
allegiance to so-called Islamic state
and on New Year's Eve in Cologne a crowd
of young Arab men sexually harassed and
abused several hundred women as the
police helplessly looked on but the
Chancellor has remained undeterred and
this summer repeated her promise from
the previous year this time however not
quite so upbeat in tone she now had to
address fears among the population we
can do this just as we've already done
so much over the past 11 months and
that's why we're also going to overcome
this new challenge facing us called
Islamic terror the very thing except she
tends not to bring up that name while on
her campaign tour of
mecklenburg-vorpommern Mackel is meeting
an agricultural cooperative in the tiny
village of sins o / venison and beer
local farmers want to hear how she
envisages their future
the pressing issues here are the price
of milk crop protection regulations
biogas but here to the topics of war and
refugees come up I think I speak for
many when I say that we're concerned
about the current foreign policy of
Germany and the EU I'm genuinely scared
looking at the various Wars all around
the planet about whether we're going in
the right direction we are working 100%
to ensure that our children and
grandchildren can also live in peace
and the basic guarantee for us is the
United European Union concluding the
question-and-answer session here to
angela makka only mentioned the issue of
refugees when asked and even then made
only vague statements but she did
deliver plenty of nice group photos
together with the men and their machines
enough to satisfy the host but not to
explain the Chancellor's policies